you know it's always been just got
genuine love like no one nothing from
you but you to be good that's it so then
I seen the pot guy like oh this is dope
and then I'm checking it about I'm like
go on folks wherever because ever loves
money I'm gonna see it you know I'm
saying I see that as genuine like every
solid yeah
so let me Epke nected on instagram
though it was like it always happen the
way it's supposed to happen everybody
welcome to another episode of hot box
and I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike Tyson
I'm like we've got a blast from the past
here baby
that means my brother's right here Manny
and Mike welcome guys tell me one thing
though this is house before we say
anything you know I was in a master
square garden gym in Phoenix Arizona and
I met Manuel that 97 what was there was
a 96 or something like that
wow man and then you can even coming in
my workouts watching them write and
watch me work are coming in my workouts
then you start sending us to your fights
we've gone through your fights in Vegas
went around fights yeah the first one I
was a friend I thought would give
tickets away yeah my friends francois
both does yeah yeah that was my first
pro fight that i've watched that was a
little scary look like he was trying to
do something for me when i sit out there
no I was telling no I was getting mad
that he was fighting so hard yeah guilt
really died I remember exactly where I
was sitting and exactly what I felt when
you hit him with that right and it
wasn't you felt listen I didn't feel
nothing it felt like I missed right cuz
you didn't even extend really you didn't
have to pull he came right in juice boom
he walked in mmm yeah that was my first
experience
that was my first on one of Vegas feel
seeing all those people in star there
was that was a highlight of my life
you know when you give me tickets I was
sitting oh who was that sitting behind
us
who's that slippery it was a lot of the
narrow one of them they were sitting
behind they never was we are excellent
season world we cook the shot the
knockout you felt it you felt the tug
you did just hear Felton right yeah the
reason before we get into what they're
doing they were just good people and you
do that when you meet cookie when you
meet good people you just do that with
good people you don't have to know much
about the weaker people you know this is
good pieces connected yes this is good
people he need to be around this more
you need to see what we do you know the
people you don't let for my experience
in life I don't let everybody that close
to me yeah then you feel good people
yeah the people uh there's a lot I'm
sure it's a lot might you need so many
people and I haven't met as many people
as you but so it's a lot you probably
don't remember but you would take me out
with you we went out right and
Scottsdale and stuff like that and not
just that but like the stuff that you
would do at the gym like you were paid
for people's quinceañeras for their kids
and like you did so much good stuff for
people using I all right so my my
introduction of boxing was you that was
my error but my dad did send me give me
all the Muhammad Ali tape so it was you
and Ali all right but as for growing up
watching it was you so you as my god
Brooke we all from Brooklyn like the
whole nine right so I grew up like Mike
Tyson is it that's it and not just the
boxing side like you're a cultural icon
whether you see it or not you are you
clearly are right so when we actually
met you I was like wow first time you
guys met and Phoenix and this is my this
and this this was my first time my first
time seeing Mike I'm sure you don't
number you pull up sitting in the back
of a rose voice you got a driver and
y'all was bumping boots hanging like a
black King Young Saeng bumping wu-tang
on shorts casual the back of Rose was
ready for the gym ready for the gym
Mike loved rolled up in five or six
black SUVs and he had an entourage they
didn't like me because they didn't know
who I was
you know why I think they like you
because you will yeah I was telling one
time I'm watching you train and you just
wasn't into it that this particular day
and you this is when you had on what's
the guy he's a trying to Holyfield -
yeah but yeah so you was like half a
city mates he said I'm done and then
everybody was like good job champ good
job champ and I was appalled oh it's not
a good job like why they saying this I
was too young to say anything I like
what I mean but my dad y'all connection
was real you know but I felt like you
have people around you to just want to
be around well I wasn't
I can't blame him I would want to be
around me to a value like I don't want
to be around somebody just to be around
like if I care I gotta say yes say some
like they was letting you not train
you ain't saying and applauding you
that's great I hated that I remember one
time I came down to the gym like sit man
you got your car with you I said yeah he
said let's get out of here I said you
know what go where yeah it was it was a
daytime party in Arizona he got a thing
they called it once a month everybody go
to one bar
what's the name of the bar oh man I
forget am vets I think wasn't even a
black born the hood yeah that's the
Legion he said what is this man it's in
the daytime why all these people in here
they all suddenly says hey Mike Tyson's
in the house Mike said Manny I want to
do no signatures of nine I said okay I
said I'll handle it I said matter of
fact my stakes are raised
you only meet Mike I talked to him about
it we had a good time we got back your
count was mad at me
where'd you take him I said man talk to
Mike he your boss man Dan guru
flew me out to Vegas to see your first
show oh I did yeah I remember the we ran
into each other at a la fit expose some
years back when you was first doing the
arm the one-man show yeah and then yeah
a ball pops out and and we saw the show
and they said you agree I said uh they
said it's about $600 I said no just tell
Mike man who was here they went back and
told you they said man Center back here
back there
[Laughter]
so this is what I want to see - yeah
what's been going on in your life man
every time I see him is always positive
you always look good healthy focused
he's always serious man I want to you
know a lot a lot a lot of growth um you
know I stop boxing earthlike early 2000s
and I just you know but you know as you
know boxing is a hard sport and training
and as soon as I found something I
thought like I could make a living I
said I I'm good right I don't need to
only do boxing more so I did that and
along our that route you know just
growing up making stupid decisions and
you know I went through a lot it's like
I ended up you know I got back in the
street I was you know doing my thing and
then I caught a case a big case it was
like kill tonight no I mean you know not
as you know it was a self-defense
situation
and uh and I became a fugitive I went on
a run and I don't want to be separated
for my children because it was coming
hard like Arizona Rome is like no reason
there's no logic behind howdy so you
know I like [ __ ] it I'm not going to
jail so I just left and I wasn't running
I was in hiding in plain sight right I
was in California next state over and I
went through a lot and I kind of I I
completely rebuilt my life even when I
was in the streets I was still I was
growing out of that so I was like you
know I would think about my grandparents
and how embarrassed I was if they can
see me right now so I was evolving at
that time and when I when I left I
wasn't in communication with anybody
that I knew barely would like send
messages to my dad and I had I don't
know if you remember this part but I've
always been really self-sufficient and
resourceful you know I've been in other
countries about myself and just figured
it out so this one time I was running
out of money because I'm a fugitive and
I hadn't eaten for like two days like
and I was like homeless like I didn't
tell my dad a lot of this stuff and uh a
couple days like I'm rough it out I know
I got something coming on Friday
whatever and I was like the only way I'm
gonna eat is I'm gonna go still and
that's raising my possibility getting
arrested and it ain't gonna just be four
step theft they're gonna Know Who I am
and take me back and you know me so I
broke down and and call my dad cuz I
never did that so it was sold like as
I'm talking to him like I couldn't even
say it without like my voice is cracked
and he didn't finish it he says how much
you need were you at and you send me
$300 and that $300 was everything to me
you know what I mean
and you know like I had before that
right before that a few months before I
had the big house all the cars the
jewelry everything
Scottsdale it was all gone stripped
right I had cars like everything's gone
to be in from that to being on the
streets like homeless
is a huge contrast it's not like I was
some bummy cat and just this is my
existence
now listen brother um the distance from
the limo and the gutters just one step
one stuff yeah that's true I can attach
food I was there like that
so that but my dad he gave me that that
just man my dad like I felt so much love
from him and my dad is the reason why
I'm such a survivor like my dad he gave
me all the tools so and then my son like
once I so I figured out I can get a job
right I don't know if I could do
anything in my idea would be and the SIS
I didn't know nothing I took a chance to
apply for a job and got a job okay so I
saved up enough money to move in with
somebody's looking for a roommate my
okay save up enough money to get my own
place with a movement and still gonna
have a car I have nothing in my arm
I was angry like I was so mad because I
was a boss in the street and it was
people under me that was happy that I
was they thought I was done happy life
and talking I'm hearing it and I was
soaring I wanted to go back and just
show up on people's doorsteps and it was
so I know that the you know just do bad
things to people and my son's mother
shot at the Vanessa she sent my son out
to be able to stay with me for a little
while and I don't know why because I had
my life was a mess
it really didn't and she's not she's a
smart girl so that kid loved me so much
it made me love myself because I was
like how is this little pure soul why
does he love me I have nothing to offer
you know I mean and that right there it
just lit something in me you know a
upward trajectory to not succumb to the
conditions that I put myself in right so
I fixed everything I controlled my life
and that's what I believe I'm the
architect of everything that happens to
me and that's what I live there
so you start working more saving money
started a business you know everything
was doing great and here it is I got
this great life but guess what I'm still
a fugitive six seven years pass I'm like
maybe you don't care the social media I
am is like I didn't intend for me to get
big on social media I was trying to
avoid it but it just happened and uh
people just gravitated towards me and
one day in 2013 2014 I was actually
sparring and I come outside me and my
boys I was sparring come outside taking
a break to walk my dog I seen I do
walked in the gym and my gym like
there's only certain people come in that
gym so this do Jiu Jitsu is a black dude
didn't look like so it's like you are
the gangbanger or powerless you know
it's not good you see him right he was
just a regular dude and I speak to
everybody it was somebody doing he was
like nervous like I was weird and then
the next thing I know sheriff's car on
Marc sheriff's unmarked unmarked sheriff
searched they came and his US Marshals
and they come hard but they came to me
there was like like gentlemen you know
and they said yeah we've been following
you for a while and know who you are who
are you like you tell me what do you
know but uh you know he said I remember
this guy he said I'll look man you do a
lot of good for a lot of people just get
this behind you move on with your life
you know he took me down to the
substation he came in he gave me a pen
and paper he says here's your phone you
need some numbers I like yes please
he said anything you'd like me to do I
said can you call my father and he did
right he called he called my dad told
him what was up and I decide to do it
deal with it you know I had to sit I had
to sit in California for a while before
they actually died I went through the
whole process and got out got to Arizona
bonded out got a amazing
he shot the Brian Russo I love him to
death I love by Russo when he was
expensive and I want to pay him extra
you don't say I know those I felt that
way too before yeah so so far they and
beat it you know and I in life is good
it couldn't be better
it couldn't be better than card is great
yeah
it's amazing yeah so many you you boxing
is part of your life I grew up I used to
box a little bit PA ELLs of Brooklyn
mm-hmm bed-stuy gates Avenue Howard oh
yeah but I never went pro but I loved
the sport and I made sure my son I
introduced him to the sport just so
he'll have confidence in himself and he
could take care of himself because the
difference between a kid who can't
boxing a kid can it's a big difference
but I taught him to respect that sport
don't you can't be a bully it's like a
loaded gun you can't play with it
somebody come at you even walk away
you're in control somebody step too
close take care of them I used to get
phone calls he's about 14 I get a phone
call from the police officer we have
your son down here I saw what's going on
I said well he's on a bus and he knocked
the man out
he said the man approached him sexually
I don't know okay cool man turning
himself yeah what Danny got him and uh
he just evolved and to be honest with
you this young man had Talent he could
have went a long way but he you know he
wanted to start a rapping yeah and he
got good at that but I still said the
boxing he was a natural you know yeah
yeah yeah I think that's what it was it
was like um you know how my dad but it
was outside of there was no support
system yeah being a black fighter in
Arizona is no
teams it's a hard law sir you know so it
was just it was it's people understand
like like when you got a supplier I'll
get it for you right he got his
entourage he got that makes it easy it
makes it easy it's old fan when you buy
yourself doing it it's I used to show up
to fights my coaching by myself
literally by myself but I'm like this is
not fun you know I'm saying and the
older I got I just kind of rebelled
against it you know what I mean the
discipline yeah structured you know
anything instruction as you get older
you go to repeal mmm I'll submit to it
yeah right yeah interesting interesting
how that happens
I like however though you know it took
me a few years like I when I stopped I
couldn't even watch boxing cuz I loved
it so much not seeing guys that I knew
that I was better than me and I love
making money I like soccer and watch
boxing it took me a couple years all
money's not good money though right but
when you young he's like man well you
know these guys but when I start back
you know I love I love boxing with
everything right so I got to a point to
where I was like I want to start
cuz I'm cool with so many fighters I
would like maybe I'm gonna start
managing some guys help them make some
money and I'm talking to one of my guys
about it and my son is listening and I
like NASA I should just get back in in
time throw and his eyes lit up but I did
I did I would tell you why Mike I did
because I said why I said you only fight
yes yes yes I said okay so I did because
just a challenge myself it wasn't like I
was trying to make a career out of it
but just to get in fights shape which is
different you know I mean it's hard and
and I just wanted that on my my thing
before I die you know I'm saying yeah so
in some for my kids to be proud of so so
I did it last year and it was hard as
hell you know I mean it's raining how do
you control your emotions in that
situation
as our I mean that's one of the hardest
things in life controlling your emotion
it is yes Mike would you say you felt
very lonely in your boxing career
absolutely yeah absolutely that's why I
was after I finished running I would go
to some girls house right like if one
when I get run that come on cause I'm
coming over there he's like fine people
to get around yeah yeah yeah but people
would think I was breaking training cuz
I was going to the girls houses and
hitting I was but I was lonely
no just over there to talk to someone
good after I finished running it was
five o'clock in the morning I can't
sleep and I'm up I want to talk to
somebody I got to do with the exercise
tips I said when I do it over the girls
house I would do the same thing I have
some comfort but I can still hug her or
something kids her mom near yeah you
should like get up and walk like ten
miles to everyone I walked him out I
remember one day he called me said Manny
I said yo he said oh I met so-and-so on
Van Buren I said okay he says uh and I'm
going to the south side why don't you
come walk with me I said man you crazy
no hustle
I said 120 degrees out there I said I'll
beat you over and I met you
it's on used to walk that fast people I
read about these great gladiators from
each time these creeks and minute I
cannot survive a walk 20 miles a Holley
invented the marathon by running 26
miles to relay a message so I said I
want to do that I mean this walks
26 miles to did it I love psychology my
feet felt like they took a [ __ ] blow
towards him yeah if it good it was hot
now yeah yeah yeah getting shaped like
that extreme about being in shape
it's funny when I'm before I quit
fighting I was like I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go go hard with this was around
you and I'm getting tatted up my dad I
was doing that
I'm worried about it and to me it was
like war markings right yeah
and I almost got your face - I was so
people got this tattoo and if you're out
there [ __ ] my [ __ ] I got talked out
of it I mean I really I don't know how I
ran into you talk to your something and
you sent me your gloves with that tattoo
one there's a lot of the little stuff I
gave my son one of the gloves I kept one
of them well the best part is what Mike
was gonna get tattooed on yeah demeaning
[ __ ] but you know that tattoos like a
landmark yes yeah you set it out there
yes it's a Maori warrior son yeah yeah
tell us more about you business than
your pop yeah I want to know how well I
guess you were around training your
whole life basically and what was sort
of the first step you took because
you're really man I mean you know I hate
to use this term just because you're way
more than this but you're you're like it
you're a fitness guru you know
everything you do with training and
nutrition and mindset around how how
people should approach training and
you've got a massive following there and
you've built an incredible business I
was talking to Sean earlier about the
products you guys sent me home with it's
my favorite protein powder I've ever
tried perfect mate with plants that base
we got to get some for here like you
would love it it's plant-based vegan
okay he's all plant-based it's awesome
products but what was the first step
like how did you [ __ ] even figure out
that you could use social media to
promote this way of life and this
message well initially um I wasn't
trying to social media was starting
online all right
I used it to like track my client's
progress mm instead of um you know
having a before-and-after picture I will
have a video of when Jennifer can do
couldn't do a pull-up and now she was
doing ten you know I mean I thought that
was more compelling than a
before-and-after picture yeah for sure
that was getting me more business more
clients right so every now and then I
told myself up there working out right
and people really liked it you know and
I think it was just the type of content
was attracting people to follow it and
share it and subscribe to what I was
talking about so then I start doing more
long-form videos on YouTube and of my
strategies and my training and my
training always stood out because when I
stopped fighting and I was just lifting
weights lifting weights to me it was
just too easy it wasn't like when you
boxing training you drank you you leave
it all on the floor
well weightlifting I didn't feel that so
I just made it more intense right so and
people they thought it was cool they
liked it so so it just grew it grew and
people just start at at like liking me
as a personality or whatever and I
wasn't really trying for that I was just
got a nice person no money so so the
following start growing and then you
have but I was still training people and
I was getting to the points where I was
getting burnt out like like I've burnt
out trading feed like all day every day
and people will come in halfway through
the day and I'm like mad because I'm
tired you know I mean I need I need to
do something so I didn't take
supplements before but then I started
taking like fat burners or just for
energy and I like the energy but in like
everything else I would feel nauseous so
I have anxiety yeah so I was like you
know what let me I started taking
pictures of the ingredients I don't have
a science background or any of that so I
would take take that and after work our
research I will go look up each
ingredient and see what it was and try
to figure out what did I like in these
products and what I didn't like okay
once I identify that I start ordering
the stuff that that
to test on myself that I like so I kind
of like started making my own little
formulas you know like my kitchen at the
time anybody know me on that time my
kitchen look like a like a laboratory
yummy I'm ordering all the routers and I
have milligram scales and gram scales
and and I'm just making my own
concoctions and then as when your social
media grows I'm sure you like because
you're Mike you got a lot of people
coming at you with pitches like hey you
want to partner with this or do that
somebody so people start reaching out to
me like hey you ever thought about this
now and then I had a guy who who had
experience in manufacturing supplements
reach out to me like hey you ever think
about doing this I said actually I'm
kind of doing it but just for myself and
we started talking about the formula
what I'm doing how okay you want to do
that for real whatever I guess yeah I
didn't think I noticed so we came up
with the formula that I came up with and
made a pre-workout and this [ __ ] worked
out you know so the pre-workout was the
first liver first thing yeah and then I
kept Adam Warren one more and then that
became a real company you know and it
grew it peaked because my partner like
he was content and I wasn't you know but
also I wasn't like over you know I had
that company for a few years I sold it
last year I wasn't really into those
kind of products anymore and this is
when I had already stopped eating meat
and I was eating one meal a day and I
was trying to take my health a lot more
serious so one meal a day for sushi with
some berries and that justice system is
getting less work young opposed to three
times a day which system will last
longer
Verdell good because you have the leaky
stomach syndrome you get that yeah it's
a lot of issues that's juice in the
mornings excuse me juice in the mornings
what are you juice many different fruits
okay Plus every morning I have a
teaspoon of garlic and honey mmm let it
sit go right through the head with you
go all the way yeah and then I take
apple cider vinegar yeah I do a
tablespoon of olive oil and vinegar yeah
then some days when I juice you don't do
this every would I juice beets apples
for the taste
that's natural sugar beets apples and
some celery just tastes nasty if you
drink it by itself
doing good doing Incan warning you see
is so swelling yeah yeah let's say you
want it yeah [ __ ] yeah you don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but you don't [ __ ] yeah
the truth as a teacher slogan yeah
absolutely yeah Mike so you're on the
one meal a day as well right which I
think for a lot of athletes might think
that's crazy
mmm you know they keep all the muscle
mass that you hold on to listen you know
not crazy because listen the greatest
riders that ever lived they look at
their marrow and a bone they're all
vegetarians and vegans and that violent
sport now this is violence portly the
vegan competitors see I got a I got a
notion about the one minute day right
and this is watch over you they think is
so crazy I might look if you're not
doing it you can't speak on it if you
haven't experienced it but this is I see
we live in a world where there's an
abundance of food right we this is new I
mean our species has been around for
about hundred thousand years we've been
kind of civilized for around ten
thousand years no no no we've been
around the oldest human being for many
years
I mean our artists our genus or Homo
Sapien yeah yeah yes it's a lot of
humanism it's funny because Sean and I
and my son we've eaten a book sapiens
right now oh yeah so it goes into that
all the different human evolution but us
Homo sapiens sapiens by reader youngest
ones we're new right but most of that a
lot of that you know like animals you
know and then even being civilized about
ten thousand years ago it wasn't a lot
of food like there's no convenience
stores there's no yeah so we will go
days without eating and then when you're
hungry you go on you go find food on an
empty stomach
right so here it is we we don't have to
do that food is all around us and like
it's a it's a reason why there's a
quote-unquote hungry mind state yeah
that's literal and figurative I know get
it when you hungry I don't get it
there's no full mind state yeah I'm
saying yeah so like when I eat I want to
relax I want to keep my feet up you know
so to me recovery to I want to go out
conquer my
they trained do all the things I got to
do around five or six I eat and I relax
my day is done you know so because I I
know me I don't operate well with a lot
of food in my system you're not suppose
to is the fact your body's working and
it can't work when you congested right
yeah that's why you have less food you
always fentons when I don't have no food
I'm always ready yeah no food there's no
there's no fuel but it's energy yeah
because energy and fuel cycle ah yeah
Smike did you eat on days that you
fought today therefore yeah yeah yeah I
couldn't eat I could never eat tea and
that's the thing
you can't let your emotions and your
feelings control you you eat no you say
everybody saying I can't eat my body no
you control your body your body's
purpose only to cover your brains to
serve you your body can't tell you what
to do brain was dead tired yeah well
yeah for sure uh I get that though and I
think I've heard you say that many times
yeah Mike about the hungry mindset and
you know you're not hungry
when you're full of food yeah you know
so there's no sense of urgency to go out
and do anything absolutely and you're
more long ago because you're not as
agile more alert and plus from the
enemies people are conditioned to eat
out of memory oh look what time it is
yeah yeah there's not a good habit
matter of fact if the FDA right yeah it
food is the drug exactly yeah people get
addicted to food in their life is over
there exactly this day imprisoned in
their body
exactly you should eat three times a day
yeah get your three square meals yeah
yeah I know got only 50 [ __ ] if you
won't eat let's eat [ __ ] I get it out in
a room
if I worked for me he was very kids I
got a I got a ship first before I could
eat again
I love he won't leave food on top of
food he had one meal he won't even let
make sense make sense I tell people all
the time it's like food is literally
fuel for your body
I always faith food is the enemy and so
much food is the enemy dear I can be
right pork left of all in preservatives
preservatives all that syrup and all
that stuff left the enemy yeah candy
bother and why do you think candy bar
the name with masculine names and look
like people's dicks you know if I call
it psychology psychology the three
musketeers pay then that dick me I
[ __ ] that pay David Snickers huh
Snickers laughing at you Reese's Reese's
Jeffery no but really this is totally
it's promoted that way yeah candy bother
you they hire people did think lemon oh
yeah all of that is important I don't
eat me right I'm riding somewhere on the
little a Vegas and I'm seeing this just
a fried chicken barrel I don't know
chicken but that look good but I did I
say where's that place ass I don't eat
me but it struck my attention it got my
attention and I said it looks good my
minds about don't eat that [ __ ] imagine
if I did I would go right there cuz it
pulls me I'm gonna give you another
example I have a friend
shoutout to Gary Gary he uh he's he was
Optronics and used to do the eyeglasses
and stuff he told me that the owner of
that place had a special rug design when
you go and sit down you look at the rug
your eyes like you need glasses
mm-hmm just go in look at that wrong he
says I said nice tie said yes Wow I said
seriously said yeah that's deep the
artists regions a [ __ ] [ __ ] it
is like me right if I want to persuade
somebody's family in here and their
mothers
should I put it back let's go to the
movie so I get a pack of popcorn I put
it in the [ __ ] here this beep
microwave take the bag throw it outside
opening and parents coming what's that
hey my let's go to the movies sure
does that cool they get popcorn it's all
about persuade is all about
psychological this ain't a word that
brings them to the moment of better
times you know what do you think about
my like we know that you conscious of
that right and I feel like there's a
small percentage of people that are
conscious of these tactics and aware of
them and we may even use them and most
people aren't you know they just don't
see it they don't get it you know is
there something to that do you think
that about having conversations about
this recently over the past few days
like the evolution of man like we kind
of talked about it on our part kept my
podcast and I feel like I don't think
that people are getting Dumber or
smarter I think it's always been the way
that it is a small percentage of people
that kind of get it a large percentage
of people is it really - because um
there's more information now even if
it's fake information is movement so we
under the notion that we know more than
somebody 10,000 years ago probably we
don't know what about the our notion of
like let's say the scientists or
whomever before said they got to this
point for us to start here and get it at
that point you know what I mean and then
whoever's after us will build on top of
that listen um we're gonna evolve
recallers who did it what did how it's
been done we're gonna evolve we finally
involved to evolve the self-destruction
you know me but um the world does still
flourish I agree with that I don't think
people say that we're destroying the
earth I don't think we can I think we
can destroy ourselves we can conceive of
the earth right we weren't even fully
understand what people told it we know
nothing about it for it for this you
know me for my simplicity we know
nothing about this place
what who are you who
you think he said she'll follow him in
him and his lemons woman gets had you
and that's it
mmm that vessels you know mm-hmm what do
you think I just think you will figure
it out when it's over mm-hmm you know
yeah
like thinking about it though think how
great death is going to be right for
this great thing about death ugly that's
gonna be I look at it from that
perspective so you think it's a another
stage of consciousness absolutely is not
is not just nothing just da Pinkett is
too thin I think every time I go to
sleep I die cuz there's nothing if I
wake up I want to know if I was telling
nice I didn't wake up well I'm sleep
it's just a bliss
nothing on the scene I don't hear
nothing and I don't sigh nice wake up so
the testicle SteriPEN attest that
there's nothing mmm that's it's fun is
easy I'm having a ball sleeping I feel
great
I don't know wake up I don't fear death
what I fear about that is the fact that
I have relationships with people that I
love and I won't anymore yeah I don't
know well know that in my mind when
lights is out is arrived I don't think
it's over listen look at your fears you
fear that it won't be important when you
wanna exist no more that you can't hear
your main mentioning your praying them
it's your ego torturing you right now
somebody and you're not gonna exist no
longer what we're gonna do to prevent
that listen you've been divinely guided
ever since you didn't do this you think
you're smart enough to put yourself in
the suit that your ego tell you are
Carthon guiding you just gonna I'm
taking your time to go them take you
then too he's been doing it all this
time it's like oh stop trying to think
it out you never know stop leave it
alone thank you let him take that's deep
Mike
like that I like that Mike so
philosophical
yeah like this philosophical because we
don't know anything but we want to
definitely know but we want anybody else
then the think that we know something
but the fact is how can we tell them
that we don't know anything and we try
to control everything and we don't have
to we have no control exactly that's a
figment of our we can't even control
ourselves exactly we let it flow and
that's where we go I think we can
control ourselves for an extent to
extent well no you can't stop this stuff
from taking the [ __ ] mmm
I don't want to stop skin stops yeah oh
down well you can control you can learn
to master your mind yeah in my abilities
betray you because look most people it's
like you're driving a [ __ ] motorcycle
down a one lane highway a thousand miles
an hour and [ __ ] [ __ ] fly animals are
crossing people are crossing other cars
are crossing and when you don't have any
control over your mind that's gonna
there's gonna be a lot of wreckage you
know but when you learn to master your
mind and control your emotions and
feelings which that doesn't mean that
they don't that they just stop coming
that just means you stop reacting to
everything you know you get yourself out
of the reaction phase and into being
able to take action when you feel it's
necessary or when you know it's divinely
guided like even a with the toad I know
you have you doesn't totally be
interested in doing anything you know
what at for a minute I was right well
not the toe specifically about ayahuasca
right I didn't know about the toad and
Trust I wash myself honestly and I've
told me a lot about it but here's the
thing so I've been meditating since 2016
like heavily and for me meditation with
me eating properly
being physically active does a lot for
me right and I feel like it's enhanced
me in a really good way
and the ego dissolution that I hear
about so often I feel like I've
experienced that however I felt me
personally I feel especially in my field
of work and just the people that I'm
around
I felt like my ego is necessary at
certain times I benefit from it but I
kind of I kind of control that you know
so when I needed I pull it out and I
know what I'm doing you know but but
outside of that I get it and not just
that just certain things certain
situations that I've been in in life
like total isolation you know I've been
in you know in other countries for
months by myself
right with a huge language barrier you
know and people having basic English but
it's like it's like there's no English
so all of that like brought me to where
I am now how I think now and you know
from what I've heard from certain
psychedelics that I was really
interested in experimenting when people
that tell people that I trust they're
telling me the the benefits from it I
think I already experienced that you
didn't never experience this I know the
total is the next level
no but knowing the kind of energy that
you give off and the kind of person that
I believe if you want to be after do the
told you would you would advance to that
person quicker than you ever anticipated
yeah it wouldn't necessarily like
destroy who you are you know it would
just amplify anything as you are and
keep you in there oh my god you do
manage to stay out of [ __ ] let me just
stay out of [ __ ] keep my nose clean and
be the best person I could possibly
mm-hmm and that's just what I got from
that right made me reach my highest
potential so far
but you do you feel like because some of
my favorite things to watch of yours is
your prison interviews you were you were
like in a different space or just it
shows you know I show people these
interviews all the time like oh you
should watch this you should watch this
you know and in my mind I was thinking
like since because I've been isolated
you know I was like that's what that is
like he's dealing with herself brother
my my some of my arm some of my biggest
peaks in my own personal growth is when
I'm alone when I don't want to be alone
you know like I like you like I want to
have a girl around just for company like
this sometimes being yourself to just
you know yourself yourself brings up
[ __ ] you don't want to bring up mm-hmm
I think it's necessary to face these
demons sometimes and you can't face it
with people gotta be other demons only
come out when you're alone yeah that's
absolutely true
and some that I've learned is physical
pain is nothing to me the emotional pain
is is heavy so I really trying to like
run after that like that bully I'm
explaining this emotional stuff the
motion stuff so anything that we have
everybody is emotional and the reason
that we are emotional because we allow
our outer life to interfere with our
inner life we let the out here get
involved in here and then our motions go
[ __ ] whack mm-hm
you know it goes whack and so that's why
my whole objective is just to be more so
distant from out there I don't let this
and when you say out there what is that
the world everybody out the whole thing
out this anything that's outside of my
[ __ ] circumference well it's the
world and there's my
yeah that's peaceful I control the piece
in there and if I was out of the world
make this in the world I'm peaceful I've
lost I might be improvement I might have
a choice anything can happen
why what do you think was your biggest
battle which personal demon for you was
the biggest one to fight
no self-worth ego I feel like that
what like giving yourself to my self
worth nothing giving it enough not
enough like thing what the [ __ ] I got
all this money for why am i doing all
this [ __ ] well I mean one of this guy
yeah a college degree some more wiser
than he ever was so too too much
humility no I'm an ability
it's not anything have information
mm-hmm yo I don't think y'all realize
the gravity of Mike Tyson I don't I do
and and it's okay for Mike to not get it
cuz it would be kind of weird you like
yeah I am all of that but might like you
like I have the ability of like being
involved in things and also being
completely uninvolved in things and
watching it from a straight laymen
perspective and I just want to say this
you are like there's certain things I
could say right now that you've like nah
nah nah like in terms of like boxing and
who you are in boxing and combat and
sports period like I don't even I don't
even narrow down the sports because
sports is I mean - boxing is all
entertainment so it's all these
different types of sports but you you
were the king of sports as soon as you
beat Trevor Berbick and then as soon as
you unify use the king of all sports
because we kind of talked about the like
people fear that heavyweight champion
because you can beat any man up in the
world welterweight champion can we
respect the lorises cool he's talented
little guy right but heavyweight is
different and not just that you had you
took me in your prime you were a perfect
fighter really perfect listen listen
Mike I was so much fans of yours even
before we met you it was like a family
certain things growing up was a family
thing def Comedy Jam Living Colour
Mike Tyson like who Jordan but Mike
Tyson since we were like boxing fans and
box and family used used use it right so
how you said like whoever you lost to
him like here but they couldn't afford
this time by that time right and for as
a heavy weight you been I remember I had
all your tapes and I remember you
explaining I was young he was explaining
how you being shorter than these guys
gave you leverage to punch up punching
down there's not much as much leverage
to shots don't hurt you to use your legs
I remember all of that and you know I
held on all of these words and then I
was as a child I was mesmerised by your
boxing wisdom you're naming boxers I've
never heard of you know I made me go
look them up you know and I I don't know
anybody personally that know as much and
I'm friends with a lot of boxers now
currently they don't know much about
boxing history you know what I'm saying
so that that is something you like a
scholar and that you know that's just
who I am if I was involved with
something something box I got involved
it I said I wanna know who the first
kind of ever did this [ __ ] mmm well the
first ever start the first person ever
put on the club and so I go from there
and I know their history for gladiators
that's Thai boxing first from people
being scored as captured after slaves
they make them fight each other for
money and that's they make that's how
glad you started making just people
quick sense the captive from another
army make them fight each other yeah for
money
interesting yeah so just knowing having
a knowledge and having that that desire
for that knowledge is is amazing man and
I and I go to war people all the time on
social media or whatever and and I watch
a lot of like different programs and I
like to subscribe to smart people and
then I at one point um there's one guy
he kept driving home the point about IQ
and different races have higher levels
of IQ and ass [ __ ] and we start
diving into like what's intelligence
right what about physical intelligence
right the physical genius genius mmm
there's way more important than some you
know scholarly intelligence yeah because
at the end of the day we animals and we
got to survive you know what I mean so
that's the great neutralizer for all of
those like yeah but we're animals and I
can if I had to take everything you have
for my survival I can you smart guy in
exam yeah but that's why they have laws
right even though animals and with
domesticated animals some of us take
longer to become domesticated in our
system cage cage take longer to be
domesticated in the right but but it
happens but um but back to what I was
saying initially you were the in my
opinion the king of sports
there's no basketball player I mean yeah
Jordan but it still wasn't the same cuz
basketball you share victories and you
share defeats boxing is you yeah all as
[ __ ] hot the highest of high status
no to to men when when you when you
fought Buster Douglas probably tell you
I run into my room late my head my
pillow couldn't believe it I was so
couldn't believe we all like no you see
the count you know when you're knocking
down c12 but but you were so important
to so many people especially me
especially my dad but there's so many
people but there will never be another
like you got Deontay Wilder and all of
these guys no one has like you had the
like you enter everything yeah it was
the dopest [ __ ] I used to love watching
you telling the guy will turn your
[ __ ] TV oh why are you interviewing
me that you don't saying but that's dope
because okay no but look well here that
they know here's the thing
you're a real better artist it was time
so there was times out I've been around
you in Arizona and I can hear people
around or that's Mike Tyson I'm gonna
try to hit them up for money in so
you're being poked at whether you hear
it or not you're being poked at so
eventually you're gonna have to roar on
somebody you know what I'm saying as you
should you know I agree but I think
that's just yeah I mean I really some
people might need that
the mother and father didn't do it kid
grew and something I have to leave it up
to somebody else to do it that's why I
always have to chastise my kids and let
them know when you're out in the world
to be respectful because there's some
kids that haven't been chastised at home
and when they come out in the world
that's gonna be their first inclination
would being chastised I agree I agree a
million percent people have a hard time
in my industry like sometime because
they feel like I'm aggressive towards
them isn't a third but like if you're a
bad person I don't want you to be
comfortable no way around if I'm around
so I do mean something around bad guys
know I know the damage they can do right
what bad people can do they can do some
damage that forever that negativity is
terrible the work thing in the world and
negative energy come so much faster than
positive could even think of it just
comes twenty times fast but the good
thing is I think we all right here we
could see negativity coming mmm could
feel it I could be in a room with
somebody and they they'll say a few
words no same let me get out of here
I'm naughty I was reading I was reading
about that like it was talking about
humans live in a sea of vibrations like
fish live in water they just don't
realize that they're in it so were you
walk in a room if people were talking
about you or talking bad about someone
yeah even they shut up before you come
in you feel it you feel that tension
quite right now I could feel it I can
feel it well go yeah yes I've been on
this earth longer than a lot of cars you
know I'm saying really you're trapped in
them yeah I mean part you only 4243
listen you guys was talking about the
brain and everything the brain is so
powerful that you can make yourself do
anything that you really want to and I
experienced and I only want to tell you
what the brain could do I recently went
through some surgery where they tapped
into my sciatica no about that yeah that
can [ __ ] your thoughts I had to walk
learn how to walk all over again
I did in three months
well doctor said well I he couldn't
answer the question I said well I
answered for you I'm gonna come back and
see you guys walking and I walked back
and seeing my son who tell you I've been
through some health stuff but I survived
because the brain he helped me I had a
quadruple bypass before I met you right
after I met you nobody knew it
you guys can't guess my age but I'm in
my 70s I could drop right now do a
hundred push-ups straight 125 air squats
the other day I swam a quarter mile so
the number has nothing to do it it's the
brain the mind can do anything you
wanted to do my son told me 100 pushups
right now fight for a fight that you
have won you picked the wrong guy that's
what I did the total I did the total
coaster we have to get in condition we
have a lot of work to do you know there
you go you know then we have gotten
condition I was around 60 65 pounds
since I started right hey Lloyd you look
great amazing amazing stuff going we
purchased a [ __ ] resort in Antigua
man we got like a hundred and well under
85 acres I'm gonna run to the restroom
go for the hold you down hey if we
purchased um we're caught in property of
185 Wow Wow and they they're gonna use
your land for the oh yeah it's gonna be
a resort for you to Europeans to come
over here cannabis friendly and liquor
friendly definitely gave us a casino Wow
Wow yeah we're getting ready to go to I
believe next week is somewhere to
Amsterdam it you really purchase a hotel
in some restaurant
we see okay that's coffee shop I've been
out there yeah this is good really the
Tyson the ranch is really gonna do
something everyone's talking about it
really proud to be involved
nice ice major and you have a ranch in
Vegas right no sore thumbs
um I've dumped a Palm Springs husband
Springs okay yeah out east
yeah there's it really beautiful when is
that launch next year yeah yes
no way that's amazing can't believe it
come very happy for you I'm very happy
for the car that god is great can't
believe this Mike you came a long way
man I agree came a long way and you
survived you survival driver drive yeah
most cats when it was over the box was
over terrible for them I guess um I
believed in myself and always had um
when I wanted to always had a good
foundation support team so I had to get
her hand something you said about us and
all that you got a good heart you could
separate from [ __ ] it was real you
know when and that's that's a talent
when he offered us to come to the fight
the first fight he flew us out to you
said he said y'all want to come to the
fight was like yeah I wouldn't have been
upset if you didn't make it happen but
he made it happen you know what I mean
you kept his word yeah that that was
that was major that's it a lot Lee Davis
little things this is this one coming
from where I come from the hood I'm now
come from right in the lane this [ __ ]
Senator suet and I used to know that
some of us never didn't I'm like they've
been a professional first he [ __ ]
wealthy people around
you think next to them and you feel good
if they feel that you have pride exactly
your black men they know better than me
I could I could fit in yeah I still got
my tickets yeah I got all the pictures
like I'm in when custom them I was a
little kid 14 he take us to the fight to
Madison Square Garden he was a big-time
man to back in the everybody knew him so
they let us going free we in front row
and I thought that was great we had a
hot dogs and popcorn eyes to that way
then we were in the back room and met
the fighters and talked to the fight
that's what I want to do and that's just
awesome one thing I admire is your your
love and your respect and loyalty to cus
today and he would you be like he says
little man but he's intimidating and
that says a lot you know do you think
that your career would have taken
different turns I know he passed away
but maybe he was around longer yeah
they're staying any longer
yeah because once cut that everybody was
just trying going for themselves right
yeah you bet we thought we were friends
our brothers and [ __ ] when money can't
get we were poor all the time we were in
the money came on the see world who the
[ __ ] are you I knew for Tennessee [ __ ]
this guy 15 you know there's a crazy
mother he's out to get us now are you
think you know the guy you don't know
right a lot of friends family a lot of
people wanted to hang out come to game I
do it
I was open I was I really vibe with Mike
Wow that was [ __ ] some that Oh God
but taking to get you somewhere Oh God I
was very open you can't believe like
Mike you know I gave away a lot [ __ ]
Dennis Rodman my days here be rods
just another game
Tyson Rancho tennis school he had him on
the pot yeah
well man I'm so glad that man I was able
to help get you guys back together [ __ ]
let's not come in real quick come on
yeah absolutely
talk about the comp that just sex appeal
those pants or something don't go to
jail like that this is your head but
Nadia Ambrose a collective all right so
I had already I accompany um you know
I'll pop you might see right there all
right so um so I had a company Sean had
his company we have another party the
cup mop my freebies come here is a
typical supplement company okay you know
so making plenty of money he making
plenty of my we were all making plenty
of money and we was just talking about
like what if we came up with um could we
were all evolving and growing you know
and we're going to be healthy healthy so
and things in a supplement business is
not always super healthy is not always
that good for you there's a lot of you
[ __ ] right right this is the guy
who's taking yeah
that's easy as easy free love you put
that together right so so we talked
about look alright we making money but
let's start another company and let's
make the absolute best products that we
can make that's actually healthy for
people right it's good stuff
let's source the highest quality
ingredients right and let's not really
let's make it affordable we're not
really trippin on making money on this I
mean we don't want to lose money but
we're not trying to get rich off of this
let's just do it just because we can
because we can so so we did we did that
and it started doing so well like I sold
my other company we all just went all-in
and now it's just growing like leaps and
bounds we toil over the world on this
worldwide and we marketed by educating
people on what kind of products the
ingredients and when you don't know you
don't know but once somebody bring this
to you information your attention you're
like okay I need this you know I mean so
and not just that things that are really
good for you usually tastes like [ __ ]
absolutely that's okay but now I'm
alright with that
me too but you get adapted to that right
apple cider vinegar to sit ahead because
you know how good it is for you my
customer but for example we found a way
to take apple cider vinegar dehydrate
while maintaining its integrity and
deliver it in a capsule so you don't
have to have it be on your teeth and and
erode the enamel on your teeth well I
don't care about my teeth the fact is I
care about your teeth
everyone loves when you smile when you
crack jokes and laughs I said that's a
that's one of the best parts of the
podcast solution but we're serious about
making the world healthier in every
which way and that's what we've been
focused on we deliver products I help
with that but we also provide the
motivation and the programs both work
out wise and nutrition wise need to go
on business and some kind of food
products yeah we'll talk about that
we'll talk about that because we
actually have ideas for that beyond this
agent deals
yeah listen my you have no idea the
portfolio was vast there's nothing that
we can't do yeah I think it's close to
you together some kind of way and we
should do some [ __ ] health food that
keeps you there call keeps your vibrant
all that thing is like you watch the
game changes movie I know you did
because you were you were referring to
some of the stuff about it when you eat
healthy and when you run your body and
fuel your body right your dick is hard
that you wake up you wake up hard and
you go to bed or and you you operate at
a higher love dick stays hard my god
they they hooked me I went down and I
was on their podcast it was awesome
they're down nearby you man so you
should go in there will be yeah you
should go in and check it out and then
once I'm home I'm home we don't leave
the house yeah I'm not mad at that from
working this rat yeah about God and the
kids and love and all that you watch
your ality shows yeah yeah what show is
he watching right now if any be on face
you have you watch like you gotta walk
90 day [ __ ] huh you got a watch
murder in the bayou
I don't know megavision and about people
dying and can i know- no more I'm
fascinated by the psychology I don't do
that no more put that out my phagocytes
gonna sleep with this channel on well
that's another kind of fast no it's
another kind
yeah the following oh I've heard of that
good one I think the same way as we're
careful about what we consume like
dietary wise we're very careful about
what we conserve salutely wise yeah we
try to attack you're gonna tell me you
don't do any negative stuff but you're
watching some reality shows oh yes
childish stuff is light is light that's
childlike I get it a 90 day fiancé
we all know this is scripted stuff it is
like it's not a cop this lady enough
some guests got kilt and [ __ ] and they
chop the finger off the head and it's
funny like I watched I watched a few of
those like making of a murderer and all
that yeah and it stresses me out yeah
it's been a while yeah this show it's
just it's really it's [ __ ] up but it's
crazy
you have the insensitive to people
feeling whatever these are [ __ ] you
used to seeing people get shy and did
[ __ ] then they should happen to nothing
funny something that hey you know what
I'm gonna say this but I could probably
use a little more of that really I would
think that you're that way you strike me
that way as how it's very peaceful and
loving I know that's why I need a little
read a little bit more like grip and
grunge and I need to remember that the
world is not as peaceful and pleasant as
it is in my existence we got we have to
make it that way
that's if I strive I've taken me here
you know that eagle the eagle the eagle
wants you to UM be afraid of that [ __ ]
it yes well gift a Pew some change
yeah dude I'm just on the [ __ ]
freight train of change yeah it's my
thing my thing I love how can I point
something out like you guys in
particular and maybe man he uses this
word but you guys use the word evolve a
lot no you you have this appreciation
and recognition that things are always
in a state of ever evolution you know
constant change and turning over and you
know all of the how our consciousness
works and you know you have the flow of
creativity and ideas and thoughts and
the way you observe yourself and we are
constantly as an organism like taking
all of that information in and bettering
ourselves in some way so maybe not
getting better you know maybe we only
think we're getting better but even
think I believe in we're getting baby if
you think you're getting better you
getting better at the thought created
but I'm saying in a tainted vessel
getting better could mean not
necessarily getting better I think
anybody and anything can improve if it
wants to if it wants to one I agree if
it has the understanding of that and in
the spirit of like evolution all things
evolving I I'm with it all you know yeah
I did I did a pop we did a podcast about
who's talking about a neural link the
interface that Elon Musk is developing
to connect myself to AI and all that
stuff yeah I'm like it's great the
people in the comments was so negative
about it yeah oh this is the mark of the
beast
oh the government's gonna control your
brain oh I'm like calm down like this is
happening whether you want it to or not
yeah just like cell phones cell phone is
like witchcraft you take it back 100
years like what oh it's in a video to
some what you don't mean I don't even
understand how it works I love it you
know what I mean because I feel like
there's nothing like things are not good
and back good or bad everything is a
utility for us to apply it however we
see fit
yeah some people want to use a flow some
people use it for bad you know it's all
spirit telephone you look at it from
that way let me feel negative right
let's talk negative your cell phones on
their tracker mm-hm
we love it so much we can't get rid of
it so nowadays since we have the phones
it's gonna change when we die we get the
person we love the most our phone mmm
decided that phone is I will hmm so when
you died somebody's gonna
the phone that's that's the coolest
thing let you know what it is - is a
brain is a piece of ya brain it's a hard
drive for our brain I don't think it's
all that but um I just say I gotta go
back I too much Dwayne you know too much
drink [ __ ] all that goody stuff no I
have to go back to the in the process of
evolution every human being is doing the
best they can at their level of
consciousness so you are constantly
getting better thank my wife for doing
see my wife already know my wife and
she's no other thing is she thinks she's
gonna help the world she thinks she's
gonna help Dennis and make Dennis come
you know she really wants you know and
sometimes when you're a friend of
everybody sometimes oh you know what
explain that to me your friend the
friend that everybody your enemy to
yourself
yeah like what does that mean because
your self purpose is to help everyone
else but you you want to help him with
this a word about your to it why don't
you work with your situation artistry
that I know people are so much help for
someone else but you know but I love my
wife and she has a big heart Monsieur do
you think there's a balance that she
could achieve where she's doing both
listen I think it's who she is
it's just who she is and she said well
people are we have to accept and love
them for even the qualities that we
don't think it's so cool right that's
when you really love someone if you know
you embrace all the qualities really
love but that's just part of the game
well that that's when you really love
for my no that's [ __ ] when you
really love somebody you do this in
today sometimes you don't love somebody
used to things the only the person that
was madly in love with somebody would do
it's our choices what we do
I chose make people with give people the
perception that is love my choices but
it couldn't be love sometimes you know
love is all perception why is it called
love why didn't they come wasn't that
call [ __ ] why not why is it love what i
think i think because we why when
someone says love this is a cultist
man you know people think [ __ ] out here
else you really do I think as the
animals that we are we come up with
certain rules or arbitrary things that
once we all agree upon it then it's a
thing it's not arbitrary anymore like
like when you say like why is it called
love I think because we all like you
know it yet that's love man and woman
marriage that's what love is about
because it used to be different
like marriage was like property is like
this is my property like a slave like a
this is my woman this is my property
here's my last name like a slave but now
love is or it used to be the merging of
great families or like now we're bigger
right like Caesar and Cleopatra or yeah
clear thought is this partners business
you know that was an idea you know love
is love love is love can't be tangible
gotta be something else because it's
thought of it that makes you believe
that I have a connection with different
enough where I loved with the thought
love is just a thought no physical being
it's just you do thought of it yeah well
here's why I think you do tend to take
someone as they are you said you start
to realize that some of the things that
you think you love about them or like
about them they're all ABing and flowing
with the things that you don't like like
some of the things that you you you may
love about your wife or think you really
like they might be the same
characteristics that on the other hand
you don't like but they lead to each
other like who we are is a complete
thing it's not able to be isolated so
someone who's very emotional that leads
to them being very caring but maybe also
volatile so I was like they all go
together so we since we can't separate
it you you tend to take them as they are
and appreciate all the good things about
them and work with them on the things
that are not as favorable well if I
decide to I will yeah and that's a
decision we all get to make yeah what is
that decision based off photo excuse me
what is that decision based off of like
how would you decide why would you
decide to accept them or not well when I
accepted why would you like what what
would you base that decision off all of
my experiences to get with the person
where I thought experience
some people listen this is um from this
is a quote from the unknown pimp
he's a [ __ ] up [ __ ] but he's
all [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah I get
that I get that I like that as well
I think that's love
yeah you know for sure yeah that's the
essence of it we talk about love respect
becomes more powerful than love look how
many times love has been betrayed
other than respect has been betrayed
listen they think about the things you
did the people you love how you hurt
them but think about the things you did
with people that you respect you never
wanted to hurt them you never want some
that you and a bad spot in their mind
[Music]
50% right now 15 3 out of 4 marriages
don't work
yeah because listen listen is here so
you go skydiving and you accident sucked
up how many parachutes what's the
percentage that workman says 3 out of 4
you may go through a gonna go there so
why would you good no listen um this is
interesting
those analogy but reason why we go there
because it's a call from God you know
look the stupid [ __ ] what my
mind doing getting narrow it's time to
clean up it's a call for God you know
it's bigger than me was about the kids
now just their turn to live now it's
good it's been a moment scorpy I won't
exist [ __ ] you Michael now it's their
turn
what are they gonna do you know we're
nothing in the scheme of things
my ego told us with bad [ __ ] we
got money we got [ __ ] but with nothing
we're gonna die in a moment very shortly
see look I agree with you but I also
think that we are something because
while we're here I mean yeah we got it
we're like this right with God with dots
on a little ball floating through space
but [ __ ] I'm so proud when I see you
know my son's report card or my
daughter's dance recital like those
things and the big scheme of things like
when you think about like 3,000 people
died in a tsunami like that right how
volatile life is but how precious and
how good we feel when certain things
that we are really into happen you know
what I mean these certain experiences
see some people and I want to believe
that but it is but it's an illusion act
movies are not real but I enjoy it you
don't I mean I guess I'm in a place
where I really are thoroughly
I am very like even when I'm speaking to
people about health and nutrition I
might look guys I could get hit by a car
tomorrow
you don't even be done so it's not you
know you live like but I appreciate what
I have right now well I don't have
tomorrow well I don't have yesterday I'm
right now because your feelings are
enslaved by your emotions be they may
but but I'm alright with it right now
when I grow out of it if that's
something if that's an evolution that's
to come I mean I'm with you you know all
of those things though as we perceive
them in many ways are just as real as
the earth revolving around the Sun the
Stars the galaxies the universe because
sure these things don't happen anywhere
else nowhere else in the universe that
we discovered that we've discovered that
we can see do these dramas play out you
know this is all spirit we're all the
same thing if you believe in the Big
Bang
we are literally particles of Stardust
that made its way into a human form that
are now expressing the [ __ ] and all the
energy of the Big Bang through human
consciousness
we may have know the minerals in the
planet they made out of oil diamond
platinum exactly copper hello we are the
fovea deaf way another planet that made
the same [ __ ] - so there's all there's
an energy there's a gravitational force
there is a network of flow between all
of these things the Stars the planets
the Sun that all of it why would you
think that that's separate from us - I
don't know I know I know I saw but it's
all even I've been embracing AB like
this is all natural yeah this is all
from the earth is not some mysterious
thing and we like this some intelligent
person with a brain like mine and yours
and yours figured out how to manipulate
these elements like alchemists to where
we can transport our voices across the
world yeah people are looking at us in
these cameras what do you think about
people there's some you know crazy
conspiracy ideas about Edison stole a
lot of his technology ideas from Tesla
listen listen yeah and Edison's and why
was Tesla killed I don't know about that
but I know Edison tell you that you
gotta be a good stealing I know how to
steal so Edison's good hey Bob yeah it's
a JP Morgan stole of General Electric
General Electric for Mama
that's his Copa death that's the Edison
coming General Electric and he and they
believe that JP Morgan stole it from him
that was his scientist he was JP morgan
scientist you know it's all all of that
I mean those are just our ideas about it
being stolen and he made the light bulb
if age is so stupid well who and me also
the idea of stealing intellectual
property property like that it's like
where did the first guy get it
an idea that floated into his Mon ride
on I think J ghoul and look ideals goes
like it didn't really come from one
person it came from everything right you
know right yeah not always who does
something first but just who does it the
best and gets it out to the most name
right and who put their name on it
yeah the winners are who writes history
you know like I was watching on 300 the
other night right there's one of my
favorite movies I like that movie but
I'm like yeah why are these Greek people
got British accents that's not a thing
right and then it's like why are the
evil people black and Arab you know
saying yeah and and I'm like why okay if
you're making people look like that
why are like the 300 that story is of
course is a fiction but it was an actual
story that the deeps love lovers right I
love it like tell that part of the story
you know I'm Sam but it's like okay no
I'm telling the story so I tell the I
want to yeah at the end of the days
whoever's territory writes history it's
a greater fighting teams I love it with
the greatest for yeah it makes sense
like death listen Francis Benedict
Arnold we hit anything the traitor
Benedict Arnold's the baddest
[ __ ] and George Washington army
George Washington was jealous a phone
yeah exactly
yes crazy because that name is
associated with he's badass but look at
this we done to him right yeah you gotta
win to write history West Point all that
stuff champion and everything he's done
and now he's a [ __ ] traitor
pretty much yeah is out there yeah yeah
undisputed truthful
there probably needs to be a new book
Mike maybe you know we blow this up when
we blow this up and we get those deals
and stuff I sauces yeah and have a world
changer vitamin something with Mike and
Sean and this six-day art that's DSA
stay hard
the D Sh
I like that well here's here's the
mission that we're on we want people to
understand that the decisions that we're
making every day set us up to be able to
take control of our own health
Mike Mike I'm a space and so did I where
we were focused on our physical
performance and looking and performing
good being strong like you were as an
athlete but we evolved into the state of
like wanting to take care of our brains
and our consciousness and our
relationships and build meaningful lives
to us and to help everyone around us and
as we did that the products we wanted to
make change too and that's why we had to
create ambrosia collective that's the
products that we make now that's our a
brand where we're producing these
products that are letting people think
on a higher level take care of their
organs their eyes and etc not not just
their muscles so like one of the things
that's inscribed on our pie they you
could have big muscles but we want to
devote their all of them and we want to
take care of the body and that's what
our products do right now that's what
they're designed to do that looks great
stuff
no it's all good then we're about to
wrap it yeah so listen this is what
we're doing now man our company's worth
around 300 million bucks and killing the
game killing I'm gonna be proud of all
of us in here yeah it's real hard and
stuff yeah it's been I've spent a lot of
fun to be a part of it like they said
it's fun to watch it's fun to watch you
know I love I love I love where you was
at in the 80s and 90s I love ya right
now you know
it's all about evolving yeah I'm willing
from life 10 years now what's going to
happen there I love how all your company
and from there gonna be new minerals
that because I have some energy
yeah well I'm like I'm not happy for you
thank you from I'm so happy for yeah we
can redo that again man yeah tore hell
yeah dude yeah and Mike so when I was
watching the POC all right so when I saw
you in LA a few years ago at the expo so
this is how happen I'm gonna tell the
story like I love Mike Tyson you know I
mean I look at him like a big bro
and he was one of my childhood idols
right after my father you know
so I'm watched somebody there was the la
fit Expo and I had no interest in it
this is probably 2011 2012 so I'm just
hanging out at home and then somebody
put on Twitter or Facebook just see Mike
Tyson at the expo I'm gonna go see my
big bro so I Drive up there by myself
and I didn't know where you were at and
I just walked in and I happened to walk
right to where he was at you would like
this you were signing pictures you know
you weren't even looking at the people
right so I just stood there I just stood
there in front of you and I didn't say
nothing you had your hand out like for
the picture and you looked up it was
like look at you this is my friend you
told me to come around like look at you
look good you just be so skinny in there
he said how's Manny call Manny you
remember that and you call it you call
them that what's up Manny just shut the
line down you don't say you know and so
you know it's always been just that
genuine love like we don't want nothing
from you but you to be good that's it so
then I seen the pod catalyst is dope and
then I'm checking about I'm like yo our
folks were at because ed loves Mike I
can see it you know what I'm saying I
see that as genuine like ABS a solid guy
yeah so when me an app connected on
Instagram was dough it was like it
always happened the way it's supposed to
happen when I moved to Newport or the
area people's like yo Mike Tyson about
here I like that's dope
yeah I mean I've even seen you as some
UFC fights will be like you know we're
all from
but it'd be like a game and I'm not
gonna yell alright I'll see them we'll
run into each other you know I'm saying
I always I had confidence then we're
gonna be brought around each other some
some somehow and it happens it always
happens and this all played out so dope
cuz fiatter don't know like him my dad
and Mike [ __ ] rocks with each other
my dad loves my Mike love my dad and I
wanted my dad to see Mike so bad so this
all happened it wasn't some big scam
like okay like we play it cool we met we
run into each other then y'all call me
on the plane I like Coulomb flop pops
out don't tell nobody
there's a podcast that's okay you know
Mike do a podcast you said you ever
white before I got the car watch a lot
man you know and then I smelled weed I
still didn't put it together and I'm
saying smoking yo I seen that one
William then I looked around and I seen
him and I said that dude look familiar
I heard that deep voice your man here
said I used to be in a minute I said I'm
so glad I could help get you guys
together man he's so great to have you
man thank you my pleasure thank you
brother
no bro I love it Mike of course brother
my brother from another mother man thank
you for having us really appreciate it
man is really good right now
Newport Beach that's the permanent guest
real here he moved here last year to go
all in for ambrosia
yeah yeah office right there to buy Hulk
hospital you know what that is
no it's pretty close yeah it's right in
there that's right a Newport Beach tell
them where they can find the products
guys yeah
ambrosia collective calm or just out so
I proceeded on it whatever yeah and we
got you
we're gonna have a care packs and up
here cuz you need to we want you
drinking the planta if you're making
smoothies especially yeah Plata and then
that's our Organic plant-based protein
yeah yeah we don't we yeah organic brown
rice best thing I ever did in my life
right yeah we're idolized yeah my youth
back hell yeah
great room this is dope it's awesome
guys well Mike great show man I think so
yeah it's beautiful lot of fun a lot of
fun to have you guys yeah a lot of love
I'm gonna get to work on the Tyson
vitamin dick stays hard yeah
all right y'all well yes leave a comment
which I buy that y'all want that I leave
a comment we want the dick stay hard
pill I'm sure I'm sure most is watching
this glass from the past baby hey check
out our website hot box and podcast.com
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel we love you guys until next time
I'm Evan Britain I'm Mike Tyson vibra
see Sean tour body Manny
yeah love y'all pcs
[Music]
[Music]